you know we've been calling them it's a
it's a phrase that Majid Noah's coined
the regressive left and is that really
where they have failed us as a society
more than anything else by this mean
that everything is racist everything is
based or not you know if you if you say
anything you hate women or you hate gays
all of this this idea that people on the
other side that you disagree with can't
be as principled as you are is that
where the left has really failed you
start describing where the left is
really then I'm gonna push it then I'm
gonna put you into my heart just because
people aren't religious doesn't mean
they don't still want to be thought to
be good by their contemporaries and
their peers and it used to be quite
straightforward to demonstrate how you
were good but today we're sort of making
it up on the hoof you know I don't know
and we've got to be the most
frenetically supportive person ever of
whatever the latest rights issue is but
really the deepest desire I wouldn't say
it see from the left it's just this
whatever this movement is that's been so
gripping in recent years there's so many
people I think the predominant thing
that is is that people want other people
to be racists they want people to be
racist they want Nazis they are fighting
a war that was effectively finished
consummately seventy years ago and they
don't seem to realize it or they want to
look as brave as the people who fought
Nazism but they can do it from their
home or on skype or Twitter or Facebook
and you know these people are in so many
ways disappointed people because the
number of Nazis around these days is
quite small in number thankfully I mean
there's a supply and demand problem
there's an enormous demand for Nazis but
not much of a supply so people go
scouring around of the social media
media political landscape desperately
trying to find people who they can call
Nazis or racists in order to position
themselves as therefore anti-racist or
anti-nazi these people need
this because they need to feed off it
and their great hope is that they can
call everybody else racist win and then
be the only person standing who's not a
racist it's it's it's terrible I mean
these people are not only fighting as I
say a a pretty much dead battle about
they're wasting their lives in the
process right so is that where the the
meme of Islamophobia has come in and
been dealt with in such a dishonest way
I'm gonna guess that you you wouldn't
argue that there's no people that hate
Muslims right you agree that some people
just hate Muslims right people yeah sure
people hate people because of their
color or their religion or whatever so
their sexuality whatever but this idea
of Islamophobia seems to me that it's
taken on this new thing where you're not
allowed to hate an idea not people yeah
I think this is one of the most
successful ways that anyone's come up
with in recent years to shut down debate
it's no surprise that the people who
started off the I the term Islamophobia
the people who were keenest on it from
the outset in the 1990s onwards were
Islamists they wanted to portray
themselves as the only defenders of
Islam against these haters these people
who hated all Muslims hated the religion
it's been a trick that's been going on
for a very long time yeah we just
just to clarify that the the word came
from the Muslim Brotherhood right yeah
yeah I mean I don't think people realize
that they think it came from some
think-tank
probably in the United States no it was
just picked up by such people and I
think with a real problem yeah because
still most people when they hear the cry
Islamophobia think oh this must be a you
know some racists problem and so on and
the problem is among other things that
it's scooped up any and all criticism of
anything to do with Islam and and that
means that if you come out with the
criticism of the Muslim Brotherhood for
instance a group which is eminently
possible to criticize you are being
Islamophobic
if you say you don't like something
which may well be very fundamental to
the Islamic faith
you are being Islamophobic and that for
the time being and I think this will
change and it may change very fast and
very nicely but for the time being
Islamophobia Trump's most other things
so for instance I you know you could be
them you know is that outspoken feminist
of your generation
but if you said something that was
Islamophobic Islamophobia would for the
time being trump feminism and so on
engaged by the way go really down low in
this pecking order no one really cares
about that right actually people seem
afraid to talk about the fact that Isis
is literally throwing gays off the roofs
of buildings there's no outrage over
that right it should get it should not
be easier than this
Isis throw gays off buildings criticize
Isis and whatsmore criticize the
ideology that they are coming from meid
Isis pose an enormous problem because
Isis don't get their ideas from nowhere
they didn't invent them yesterday
they always publish long scriptural
explanations from the Quran and hadith
of why they're doing what they're doing
now that doesn't mean that people should
say Isis throw the gays off the
buildings therefore all Muslims hate
gays therefore all gays or anyone else
should hate Muslims obviously and of
course yeah
but obviously you have to identify where
the problem comes from and I mean you
know I look around I find ones of people
willing to do this at the moment you
know and they're just a quick one you
know they're I mean you always get
reached to the National Union of
students in Britain if you want to reach
for a bunch of idiots
but the National Union of students in
Britain recently didn't condemn Isis
because they said that it would be as
Lama phobic to do so so throwing gays
off buildings and raping young girls for
the alleged crime of being a Yazidi or
occurred or from a Muslim sect that the
men that men are rapists of Isis don't
believe in if you criticize that you're
Islamophobic look as I say people at
court their court and is terrible
terrible mess of half thinking and non
thinking and everyone's got to find a
way to help them think their way out of
it
but they better be quite fast they
better be fast I fear that they're not
so what would you say to the people that
would argue well we really created Isis
because we went into Iraq which now by
most accounts was the wrong war to go
into I'm not sure if you agree with that
but and then by leaving so quickly the
way we did we just it was a breeding
ground it was fertile ground for
religious extremism and all of this
awfulness to happen so that it's not
just about religion it's also about the
geopolitics can I make a point which
doesn't always go down well American
audiences but I think is worth pointing
out as an outsider of course because a
part of the American thought disease on
this is now in Europe as well but it
started with you we give you some bad
ideas and you give us some as well this
this American self obsession this
American idea that nothing in the world
can get screwed up unless it's because
of America is a intellectual disease
you've got to get over the world can go
to hell without America doing anything
the world can go to hell without America
lifting a finger but every time anything
in the world does go to hell Americans
ask themselves what is it we did or
didn't do that made this happen
that's why you still see the amazing
example of not only the President of the
United States but other senior figures
in American politics even what wanting
to apologize we know the year of the
Crusades I'm sorry this stuff happened
centuries before before the British even
discovered this happened before before
the US was founded you keep blaming
yourself for things before the creation
of America and nobody is fooled apart
from you I had a friend some years ago
who went to interview Yasser Arafat an
Iranian friend a journalist very
distinguished journalist from Iran he
went to interview Yasser Arafat some
years
he said and at the end of his interview
there was a knock on the door and one of
the astronauts goons or male friends or
whoever said chairman Arafat the
American delegation is here to see you
and and my friend thought he had a scoop
and he said to our fight who is this
American delegation and Arafat said oh
is it
it's a delegation that's come from the
u.s. to apologize for the Crusades and
an Arafat burst out laughing right
everybody laughs at this apart from you
Isis was not created because of George W
Bush al Qaeda wasn't created because of
Bill Clinton or George HW Bush there are
things that America can do well and
things that American can do badly and
there are things you've done that
haven't helped there are things that
Britain has done that hasn't helped but
it is not all because of you right so I
I do agree we have a way of making
everything about ourselves maybe it's
because we're a young democracy in a lot
of respects so we're still in our
infantile phase perhaps do you guys not
have that in England because obviously
England has done all sorts of Imperial
things far more for a far richer history
of imperialism than the United States
but we're saying you guys you guys don't
have that feeling is that not it doesn't
exist at all Britain Britain could teach
America something about imperialism and
it's east and he could teach America
something about post imperialism we've
been going through this so I mean you
know Britain like all countries are
after their height it looks over what
it's done and wonders whether it was a
force for good or ill in the world and
we have periods where we we seem to
think we did no good and other times
when when we realize actually that on
balance maybe things were better than
that maybe maybe we did more good than
we did harm it's always in the balance
it goes up and down and perhaps so it
should but the fascinating thing to me
again about this is it's so one-sided I
mean you know we hear all the time about
what empires do and about the British
Empire and about the mandate in
Palestine and about America is really
quite minimal involvement or at least
quite brief involvement to date in the
Middle East and so on but you know why
don't we ever talk about Turkey why
don't we ever talk what
the most important the longest and
largest empires in human history was the
Ottoman Empire I never hear anyone from
America or Britain or anyone else saying
you know the Turks have got so much to
answer for
nobody ever says that Turks have done so
much wrong in the Middle East and until
we punish them sufficiently you wouldn't
hear this it's only people in America
and Britain and the rest of the West
they're so self-obsessed and knows so
little history and and and what we think
is we will be able to solve it if we
beat ourselves up and we could beat
ourselves up for every year we have in
the future and it still wouldn't solve
the problems the Middle East it wouldn't
solve Iraq it wouldn't solve Syria
wouldn't solve Turkey wouldn't stop Isis
it wouldn't do anything it's a luxury
it's a luxury that I think is a kind of
decadent luxury I don't I don't approve
of it you may have may have got that
yeah I think I got that idea so it
sounds almost like sort of like you see
this as like a disease of the Western
mind sort of that we've our society
because of our freedoms has moved so far
past some of these other places that we
turn everything on ourselves we don't
realize sort of how good we have it or
something to that effect it's laziness
masquerading as moral sophistication you
know if you go to a dinner party I mean
I know you an LA something this is this
is squared for you there but if you were
to go to a dinner party and somebody was
going to save them about Afghanistan and
you wanted to say something really
clever about Afghanistan you would
probably say something about how
terrible American involvement in
Afghanistan has been if you cited any
other power other than a Western powers
involvement in Afghanistan it's not so
sophisticated you know if you go for
America or you go for Britain you go for
yourself you know you you you look like
you know something about Afghan history
which let's face it very few people do
you start to look like you know about
Afghan history and you also look like
you're so morally sophisticated that you
can even beat up on yourself and what it
means among other things is you don't
actually have to pay attention to the
world you don't have to go anywhere you
don't
to really think about things you don't
really have to keep up to date because
every time anything happens you can say
well there was that time and you know
and and just come up with some date and
and hey presto you walk away looking
like you know something and looking like
you're someone yeah you know it's funny
I never thought of it sort of through
the the prism that you're presenting it
right now but I think turkey is a really
interesting example of this because if
I'm not mistaken since 1974 turkeys been
in occupation of Assam Cyprus right
isn't that isn't this there in
occupation of a sovereign nation one of
my most salient okay all right I just
tossed it up for you take it away is the
most startling example of all you know
turkey is a member of NATO and is in
occupation of part of a European country
and I never hear anyone talking about
this I mean I you know unless you have
Cypriot friends no one ever raises
Cyprus at dinner when everyone's got a
placard on the street marching up and
down saying end the occupation they're
never talking about Cyprus right
no one ever raises it why because they
don't care and they don't know and I
know I mean it's these things you can
only point these things out and hope
that over time the trickle down of this
information gets somewhere yeah you know
but as I say in the mean time people
have got a very narrow set of facts and
the easiest way out is to think it's our
fault
[Music]